we got a ton of voicemails about my
appearance on fox news yesterday here is
I guess just one example we had dozens
of emails and comments here's one
voicemail that was left at two one nine
two david p hey david just saw you on
fox news you know i've never seen you
before you're pretty much a Weasley
little prick okay what you're the kind
of guy I bet the girls beat you up in
high school then they what a little
[ __ ] stupid weasel you are Wow
fleeting expletive fleeting expletive
dozens like that and this is why I'm
wondering is it worth doing this and I
know that some people will say David
you're hearing from the people who you
didn't convince but just being given the
opportunity on Fox puts you in front of
an audience that widely disagrees with
your point of view and it makes it more
likely you'll change minds even than on
your own program because on your own
program even though yes there are
hatreds you are disproportionately
talking to people who already agree with
your point of view on Fox News you're
disproportionately talking to people who
disagree with you and thus it is worth
doing at least that was Kyle Cole in
skis views when he when he view when he
told me you should definitely do this
stuff it may be not everyone who watches
Fox News is a committed conservative
right it would be people claim across
this interview while they were waiting
at the airport or at the dentist office
and they liked what you had to say
probably not the airport because
airports almost exclusively run CNN but
maybe at a Taco Bell Taco Bell is now
apparently running Fox News as a matter
of policy and and I actually got a few
emails saying David you got a covered
are you now boycotting Taco Bell over
that and of course the answer is I've
been boycotting Taco Bell for 15 years
it has nothing to do with what News
Channel is on at Taco Bell we've got a
great bonus show for you today France
has won the World Cup defeating Croatia
four to two this is great for me because
France was my 19th favorite team in the
World Cup and Croatia was my 23rd
favorite team so even though my number
one team Argentina was eliminated and
number two team elugu I was eliminated
and number three team Mexico was
eliminated and all of the other teams
that I even marginally cared about were
eliminated when it came down to it I
liked France slightly better than
Croatia
so in some way it was a victory well you
know what it is France defeated
Argentina and Uruguay so this just makes
your teams look better right they they
lost but they lost the champions yeah
did France defeated oh boy yes okay I
didn't watch that game I think it was in
transit at that point back from New York
City so France has won the World Cup we
will talk about that we will talk about
a game show that is looking to gamify
the student loan nightmare that is the
United States of America in 2018 for
countless former college students and
there is also an interesting story about
Trump Supreme Court picked Brett
Kavanaugh related to baseball ticket
debt and it's actually a story that has
spread to the miles and points world of
people who are involved in the churning
of credit cards for airline miles and
all of this different stuff it's a very
very weird direction for a Supreme Court
pic to have controversy but we are going
to talk about that on today's bonus show
get access to the bonus show two ways
it's really easy do it it'll feel good
become a member at WWJ ENCOM or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show you will get instant access to the
bonus show commercial free audio and
video streams of the show and you'll
have the deep down warm feelings not of
indigestion but of knowing that you are
supporting alternatives to homogeneous
corporate media will talk to you on the
bonus show